الشيء الوحيد اللي بخافوا منه هدول انه
يخسروا اهاليهم
ما عندهم اي شيء تقول لك انا اخاف انه
اصحى القى امي ما موجوده اصبح عندهم خوف
لانه احنا اصبحنا الامتداد لامان مش
المجتمع لازم يتغير المجتمع ككل في انه
يشعروا الاولاد بالامان ومن ثم بيجي
التنافس بيجي
الرغبه في انه الواحد يحقق ذاته الاولادنا
غير شاعرين بالامان امانهم احنا
فاحنا لازم نعطي اولادنا الامان عشان نطلب
من المجتمع يعطينا الامان
تخرجوا مننا مجموعه من الشباب وشغالين
الان في جهات حكوميه في ايمي كل شغالين
الان عندنا في سيمنس للانرجي وبرواتب ما
شاء الله تظاهر رواتب بتاعه الخريجين من
الجامعات فلابد ان يكون لها دول الاولاد
خبره مهاره حتى يستطيعوا ان ينافسوا في
سوق العمل حسب امكانياته
[موسيقى]